bueno buenos días a todos cómo están
mucho gusto yo soy mar se la recicladora
hernán doval a todos como es tan bueno
para los que no me conocen mucho gusto
de la recicladora nuevamente soy más
conocida como la primera recicladora
youtube que pronto ustedes me han visto
para en el facebook en el youtube en el
instagram en el tito en la televisión en
la radio bueno hay muchos lugares para
que pero me ha ido muy bien con esto de
las redes sociales pero es que digan
ustedes cuando hayan visto de pronto una
recicladora youtuber que les enseña a
reciclar así como yo lo hago con las
tres erres de fácil reclamo y rebajar
para los que pronto nos ven de otros
países o de otros lugares y no saben que
son los recicladores o los recicladores
como yo les digo somos las personas que
día a día estamos trabajando en esto en
la basura y abriendo la bolsa a todo lo
que ustedes no tienen velo que les huele
a cero nosotros estamos día a día en
contacto con eso intentando recuperar
los materiales aprovechables que no es
basura cuáles son esos materiales
aprovechables el plástico el papel el
cartón el vidrio el aluminio el tetra
pak
chatarra pero hoy no les voy a hablar de
reciclaje si ustedes quieren saber de
reciclaje de cómo se para su recibo vaya
a mi canal hoy vamos a hablar de otra
cosa vamos a hablar de mí de mí como
persona como activista como soñadora
pero para hablar de eso pues yo les toca
presentar a otra persona que tal vez
ustedes la conocen como mi manager y que
de pronto no es tan famosa como yo pero
tiene un mismo propósito un propósito
igual al mío que es generar un cambio
entonces los voy a dejar con saras
amarillo
hola mucho gusto yo soy sarah samaniego
como dijo marsé yo no soy tan famosa
como ella pero es que realmente yo no
quería ser la protagonista de esta
historia yo quería que fuera a ella
porque a mí me da mucha pena hablar en
público aquí donde me ven estoy muy
nerviosa siempre tenía como las voces
del qué dirán estaba muy pendiente de
eso entonces después si a mí me da pena
va a sacar un otro yo que no le dé pena
que diga las cosas como las quiera decir
y pues ahí es donde donde nace este
personaje que busca representar una
profesión que ha sido invisible durante
muchos años muy poco valorada y que
realmente es demasiado importante para
nuestro país para el mundo como lo es el
gremio de los recicladores que aprovecha
acá para agradecerles esta importante
labor que hace muchas veces nuestros
sueños se ven afectados precisamente por
los miedos del que diaz entonces yo
vuelvo y le reitero si ustedes tienen
esa capacidad de convertirse en otros
piénsenlo y háganlo y cree en ese alter
ego que igual no es otra cosa que una
versión de ustedes mismos pero sin todas
esas voces que a veces nos aturden y nos
llenan como
y seguridad entonces piense en ese sueño
que usted tiene en esa meta y crea que
eso es mucho más grande que todos los
miedos que puede tener adentro cuando
somos niños siempre jugábamos a hacer
otras personas a ser superhéroes
personajes de disney princesas o
personajes de novelas colombianas como
pandillas guerra y paz como saben a mí
me quedó gustando más lo último porque
son personajes que muestran realidades
que muestran cómo es una sociedad que
muestran no ese sueño ideal o esa vida
perfecta sino la realidad que vivimos
entonces precisamente eso fue lo que yo
hice un personaje que quería cambiar
corazones que quería transformar vidas y
que quería llegar a las personas de una
manera diferente desde la educación y
desde el corazón
marsé es una versión mía no es otra cosa
incluso mucha gente me dice que sara es
el personaje y marce soy yo
ahí los dejo a ustedes realmente a veces
yo también lo creo
cuando yo soy marcel no tengo que
salirme de mi realmente yo cojo todos
los rasgos de mi personalidad y los
exagero porque pues como es un personaje
necesita tener como esa recordación
ciertos rasgos característicos
a hablar su forma de vestir pero para
nada que es una burla todo lo contrario
y así es como yo logro transmitir como
esa realidad porque no tengo que actuar
demasiado sino simplemente dejar fluir
lo que yo soy lo que yo digo sin filtro
y ya está es más entonces por eso yo
siempre digo que mi ficción se convirtió
en una realidad la realidad que decidí
encarnar que decidí vivir y que decidí
sentir marc se nace de la cabeza de una
niña que siempre soñó con ser actriz con
ser profesora con cambiar el mundo y
convivir una historia de amor
sara samaniego no es actriz bueno y
pronto así nunca ha sido profesora no es
tan famosa como para cambiar el mundo y
no tiene novio para tener su historia de
amor pero decidió seguir los consejos de
la barby que dice ser lo que quieras ser
entonces ahí es cuando yo digo pues si
yo no tengo eso que marcelo tenga
entonces marsé pues no es profesora por
tener un título sino porque día a día
está enseñando en sus redes sociales
cosas muy importantes acerca de la
separación de los residuos y en nuestro
medio ambiente
marsé
sí pues ha logrado impactar al mundo de
una manera importante puede que no tenga
millones de seguidores pero tiene una
cantidad de seguidores suficientes para
generar un cambio incluso ahorita hace
poco fue reconocida como una de las 10
líderes de cambio más influyentes del
país lo cual me llena de alegría y
emoción quemarse si tiene novio tiene al
hernando que lo ama con todo su corazón
y vive esa historia de amor perfecta
viéndolo desde esa perspectiva puede
sonar un poco triste que esa hora esté
viviendo una vida que no tiene a través
de marsé pero no es así es ahora es
felizmente comunicadora social no es
famosa es feliz no siendo famosa para
que no hablen de ella cosas que no son
en programas de farándula y está
felizmente soltera viviendo de su
soltería aunque no pierde la esperanza
de encontrar a su príncipe azul
simplemente explorer una manera de hacer
una investigación en carne propia
literalmente siguiendo ese consejo de
pongas en los zapatos del otro esto me
permitió llegar a una conclusión muy
importante que tal vez ha sido de lo más
valioso de este proyecto y es darme
cuenta que estará en una persona
privilegiada y bendecida porque a
diferencia de marsé
si sara quiere estudiar algo puede
hacerlo si sara tiene frío se puede
comprar un saco si quiere comer algo
pues va al supermercado y lo compra y a
diferencia de marsé que es la historia
de más de 30 mil familias que viven del
reciclaje es una situación muy difícil
es una es una profesión que ha sido muy
poco valorado durante muchos años y es
hora de hacer visible lo invisible por
eso decidí tomar el papel de profesora
de los colombianos entender que nuestro
planeta es nuestra casa y si nosotros no
lo cuidamos quién más lo va a hacer es
momento de sonreír y ayudar al otro
sentir en carne propia ese dolor de lo
ajeno yo encarno marcela recicladora
pero mañana podría ser claudia la
celadora sonia la secretaria martha la
médico pero eso y sara samaniego y me
siento muy feliz de poder seguir siendo
yo a través de un personaje que se
atreve a cambiar el mundo
entonces les pregunto a ustedes qué
personajes quieren ser muchísimas
gracias